if you're mad with breasts and you go to
jail he just might pull his dick right
in between your hair now and I forgot to
mention while I was doing deadlifts my
mind and my arms started crapping out
and then I scraped my leg doing dead
there look at that [ __ ]
that's uh that's pain and weakness
leaving the body so Oh what is going all
my little dingleberries the third week
is now complete and you know how
everybody told me after the first week I
will stop being sore you lie mother but
to your credit though I am NOT as sore
as the first week yes I'm a villain in
fact you ever work out so hard for some
reason certain parts of your body a
sword that you didn't work out aka my
change purse aka my ball sack personally
I don't know if I should get that
checked or what but if you dude you be
single you better get that check now a
lot of you have asked the question of
the month which is David how much weight
you lose already a bottle by this voice
all the time and today I say none of
your [ __ ] business
I'm just playing but in all seriousness
I don't think that a specific weight
goal or something that you necessarily
have to have in order for you to live a
healthier lifestyle and let me tell you
why
now as you all know I have been
overweight for quite a while and every
time I try to lose weight
I used my scale as a measure of progress
and what I mean by this is that number
on the scale became more important to me
than how I was progressing health-wise
if you are obese then yet dropping that
weight number is going to be important
but let me tell you something don't
obsess over it I'm gonna put it to you
like this it took you years for you to
get this fat so what the hell makes you
think is going to take days for you to
get thin hey camel face listen your diet
is not a magic wand
this ain't Hogwarts I'm not going to be
fat anymore
is it what no you still fetish [ __ ] calm
the [ __ ] down and know that your hard
work will eventually pay off another
reason why I'm telling you not to focus
so much on the scale is because when you
don't reach that number you
automatically get discouraged tell me if
this is you you check the scale way more
than
you should and when it doesn't budge you
give up here's the thing
[ __ ] your scale let your physical
results and the way you feel be a true
testimony of your progression here let
me put it to you like this you lifted a
ton of weights you drop down your wave
size by three or four sizes and you look
great but you only lost a couple pounds
now does it really matter that you
didn't reach your weight goal do not get
discouraged by something as trivial as a
number so to go back at the question how
much weight have I lost I'm not gonna
tell you the reason why is because the
measure of my success should not be a
scale in which you baits whether it's
going to be worth it for you or not so
if you want to do yourself favor take
your scale and throw out the
[ __ ] window and I would throw
my scale up is [ __ ] window too
but it's not mine I don't own it and the
windows closed and it costs money so
that's just plain irresponsible you
don't want to do that just be thin and
smart double combo but tomorrow morning
wake up and look at your scale in this
digital eyes and say wow if you want to
take anything away from this video
remember this your scale is a measure of
your weight not a measure of your
progress so Fitness fam as always
remember light is what you make it but
it's up to you to take when you deserve
let's go for broke oh what is going on
Fitness fam
you know I'd record this twice because I
forgot to turn on the mic yes that is
how dumb I am hmm but if you have not
kept up with my tweets yes I did hurt my
lower back and I am out the gym for a
couple of weeks that's right two weeks
but don't worry I've been modifying my
workouts to adjust for the lower back
hurt so hopefully I will be getting as
much progress as I have you know with
the current workouts that I'm doing no
worries fitness fan I'm still yeah
but of course clothing is always brought
to you by go for broke apparel calm and
if you've been following my Instagram
you do know that our February 5th we are
dropping two new designs that are hot as
hell this happens to be one of them yes
yes yes but here's some good news on
February 5th all the way through 10th
you will be getting a 20% discount on
the whole on my website for all of our
merch including the two new designs so
yes happy Valentine's Day [ __ ]
all you got to do is use the promo code
broke love and you will get that 20%
discount so please make sure you use
that
so I could help y'all out on that cash
flow your game but fam keep it up and if
you guys are progressing than you are
doing those videos make sure you send it
to me be a tweet my twitter is at david
so comedy yes
so fitness fan I will see you all next
Wednesday and of course this Sunday or
Monday you will see a new video like you
always do because that's how we do we
don't stop ninja time not is what I
disappear I'm here maybe you still saw
my ass
yeah now as you all know I have been
overweight for quite a while and fun a
bit to cut my hair now as you all
already know I've been overweight for a
majority of my life which means that I
have always used a scale as a measure
measured as an edge a major above my
progress sir oh and what I mean by this
is that that specific number became more
important entity corner what am I doing
with my hands what is this tell me if
this is you you check the scale way more
than you should and when you don't it
got the date